die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis guten abend und
herzlich willkommen für den sport mit
dabei norbert lehmann
ein beamter von mir blicken wir auf die
wichtigsten themen heute jeder fünfte
zwischen 12 und 17 jahren ist jetzt
einmal geimpft die forderung nach einer
generellen impfempfehlung für kinder und
jugendliche wird lauter verwüstung und
verluste nach der flutkatastrophe ist in
teilen der eifel der tourismus
weggebrochen und olympischer rekord die
jamaikanerin elaine thompson herold in
einer fabelzeit gold über 100 meter
für viele beginnt bald wieder die schule
aber ob allen kindern und jugendlichen
eine corona impfung empfohlen werden
soll oder nicht dazu gehen die meinungen
weit auseinander
nicht nur aus der politik mehren sich
die stimmen die für eine generelle
impfempfehlung für kinder sind die
ständige impfkommission im 4c dagegen
weiter nur für kinder mit
vorerkrankungen heike slansky volksfest
in nürnberg heute mit impfangebot plus
gutschein für alle ab zwölf jahren und
das obwohl die ständige impfkommission
kinder und jugendliche nur mit
bestimmten vorerkrankungen zur spritze
rät das unkomplizierte angebot hier
kommt an meine zeit ist immer gut
begrenzt wir sind jetzt mit die kids
daher komme und jetzt kurz entschlossen
zu lassen kinder impfen ja oder nein
eine glaubensfrage
entgegen der empfehlung der ständigen
impfkommission prescht nun sachsens
eigene vor die einzige auf länderebene
sie rät nun doch impfen ab 12 jahren
es ist ein angebot an alle so wie es
auch an die älteren angebot ist das ist
ja keine impfpflicht das muss man noch
mal ganz klar sagen die wollen wir gar
nicht sondern wir wollen den ärzten und
ärzten ermöglichen kinderärzte aber auch
hausärztinnen und hausärzte das team mit
dieser empfehlung sich sicher fühlen
auch kinder und jugendliche zu impfen
meinungsverschiedenheiten unter
fachleuten auch die politik erhöht den
druck nur das impfen auch bei kindern
helfe gegen die panne
wichtig ist dass wir die möglichkeiten
eröffnen die stehen bereit und dass wir
jetzt all die impf angebote den dort
schon existieren insofern noch
attraktiver machen dass es auf suchen.de
angebote gibt und dass man auch nicht
mehr an termine gebunden ist man kann
hier nicht grundsätzlich sagen jetzt
aktuell sollten sich alle kinder ab
zwölf impfen lassen sondern man muss die
situation sehr genau beobachten wie
wirken sich neue virusvarianten auf der
kampf gegen die impfmüdigkeit und die
verunsicherung der berufsverband der
kinder und jugendärzte fordert nun eine
klare impfempfehlungen der ständigen
impfkommission besonders unter jüngeren
menschen breitet sich das virus aus sind
sie jetzt also stärker gefährdet dieser
frage gehen wir nach bei ze erfreute und
in unserer app insgesamt sehen die
korona zahlen in deutschland heute so
aus das robert koch institut meldet 2400
neuinfektionen
das sind 481 mehr als vergangenen
samstag 21 menschen starben im
zusammenhang mit kurven 19 binnen 24
stunden
die sieben tage instituts steigt auf
16,9 vom oktoberfest bis zum karneval
viele massen feiern wurden ja wegen der
pandemie abgesagt jetzt wo die
infektionszahlen vergleichsweise niedrig
und immer mehr menschen geimpft sind
geht es aber langsam wieder los
so hat erstmals nach eineinhalb jahren
corona pause der hamburger dom geöffnet
wie der jammert in pandemie zeiten
funktioniert zeigt ihnen homeyer
es ist eine art experiment das größte
volksfest in norddeutschland unter
strengen sicherheitsvorkehrungen und
trotzdem wollen viele dabei sein ob es
eingezäunte gelände kommt diesmal aber
nur wer vorher ein zeitfenster gebucht
hat getestet geimpft oder genesen ist
und die maske darf natürlich auch nicht
fehlen jeder der hier ist es fröhlich
arbeit natürlich viel viel weniger los
nur weniger menschen dass das feld schon
auch was ist nicht schlimm dass man
nicht so lange warten muss hat man mehr
platz ganz ehrlich der dom gehört zur
freiheit dazu und ich will wieder
normalität ein bisschen freiheit haben
und dadurch dass er ja alles so
beschränkt da ist habe ich auch gar kein
problem ihr ja zu kommen das entspannt
also ich finde jetzt nicht irgendwie
dass die leute irgendwie anders drauf
sind
im gegenteil die sind freundlicher die
ganzen kassierer alles weil sie sich
freue dass wir da will zum beispiel rico
rasch er ist schausteller in der
sechsten generation und gehört damit zu
einer branche die die pandemie besonders
hart getroffen hat mehr als 5000
schaustellerbetriebe gibt es
deutschlandweit nach angaben des
deutschen schaustellerbundes mussten sie
umsatzeinbußen von rund 95 prozent
verkraften
da wir in voller ungewissheit sag ich
mal die zeit verbracht wir haben immer
vom veranstalter zur veranstaltung
gehofft dass es wieder weitergeht
es ist ja nicht nur ein beruf das ist
unser leben nach jeder fahrt wird
desinfiziert markierungen und
sicherheitshinweise an vielen stellen
erinnern an die geltenden regeln
insgesamt stehen rund ein drittel
weniger fahrgeschäfte auf dem
heiligengeistfeld
dichtes gedränge gibt es auf diesem
sommer dumm nicht
in keinem anderen europäischen land
sterben derzeit jeden tag so viele
menschen in verbindung mit kurven 19 wie
in russland
lange tat die regierung so als sei die
pandemie schon vorbei etwa während der
fußball em
fakt aber ist seit wochen werden täglich
fast 800 neue todesfälle im zusammenhang
mit kurven 19 gemeldet und die behörden
erhöhen nun den druck um menschen zum
impfen zu bewegen
axel sturm ihr jänner gringo muss den
überblick behalten sie ist
stellvertretende chefärztin einer
poliklinik heute aber ist sie
verantwortlich für eine im station im
kaufhaus zwischen teuren klunker
kostümen uhren gibt sputnik wie zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt ist der einzige
schutz die impfung gerade die
massenimpfung bringt die herdenimmunität
und wird corona besiegen
viel andrang gibt es nicht auch nicht im
noblen kaufhaus zum das ist ein problem
denn noch immer wollen sich rund 40
prozent der menschen nicht impfen lassen
allerdings bessert sich das gerade vor
drei wochen waren es noch über 50
prozent
ich bin für die impfung wenn der
impfstoff gut ist dann ist das eine gute
sache
[Musik]
ich habe mich impfen lassen weil ich mir
einfach keine gedanken gemacht habe dass
es inzwischen solche bilder gibt ein
streit vor einem impfzentrum sie können
sich das nicht vorstellen es gibt schon
schlägereien es gibt zu wenig impfstoff
hat viel damit zu tun dass die regierung
die zügel anzieht nach monaten des laxen
umgangs mit der pandemie gibt es jetzt
zwangsmaßnahmen beamte lehrer
gastronomen dienstleister 60 prozent
aller angestellten in vielen branchen
müssen sich impfen lassen
ihnen droht sonst die freistellung vom
job ohne gehalt harte maßnahmen in einem
land in dem auflagen wie die inzwischen
abgeschaffte handschuh pflicht im
nahverkehr nur selten durchgesetzt wurde
und in dem es vor kurzem noch fußball em
spiele gab
in frankreich ist die korona politik der
regierung restriktiver und das gefällt
nicht allen
erneut sind zehntausende menschen wie
hier in paris und vielen anderen städten
auf die straße gegangen
inzwischen das dritte wochenende in
folge der protest richtet sich vor allem
gegen die impfpflicht für bestimmte
berufsgruppen aber auch gegen den
gesundheitspass derzeit ob man geimpft
gewesen oder getestet ist und wir
blicken auf die flutkatastrophe die
große frage hätten die menschen früher
gewarnt werden können hier gibt es
schwere vorwürfe gegen die
kreisverwaltung der besonders
betroffenen region ahrweiler
so seien präzise warnung vom landesamt
für umwelt nicht umgehend weitergegeben
worden berichtet die frankfurter
allgemeine zeitung
der rheinland-pfälzische innenminister
kündigte an die abläufe würden exakt
aufgearbeitet in bad neuenahr wurde
heute eine behelfsbrücke bei die öffnet
die größte die das thw in deutschland
gebaut hat die flut hatte mehr als 80
brücken beschädigt oder komplett
zerstört
bis überall die größten schäden behoben
sind wird es wohl monate dauern
die folgen davon bekommt auch die
tourismusbranche zu spüren sowie die
gemeinde gmund in der rureifel auch hier
viel zerstört urlaub wird hier erst mal
nicht
ferienhäuser wurden stattdessen zu
notunterkünften eine schwierige
situation für die die ein dach über dem
kopf brauchen aber auch für die die auf
zahlen der touristinnen angewiesen sind
je nach vorn
drei meter hoch stand das wasser in
gemünd vom kleinen fluss auf breitete
sich die flut im ganzen dorf aus diese
ferienhäuser blieben unbeschädigt
seit zwei wochen stellen sandra und jan
lehmann die häuser als notunterkunft für
flutopfer zur verfügung
doch langfristig werden auch sie wieder
urlauber annehmen müssen den garten den
tagestouristen den brauchen nicht das
ist ganz klar
aber jemand der hier hinkommt und auch
ein bisschen verständnis für die
situation hat der uns unterstützt der
wird der kann hier hinkommen die
unterstützt die eisdiele die pizzeria
aldi läden die offen haben die jetzt
händeringend versuchen weiter zu
existieren
18 kilometer entfernt liegt rurberg ein
beliebter urlaubsort der von der
hochwasser katastrophe verschont
geblieben ist trotzdem bleiben die gäste
weg mitten in den sommerferien seine
gemeinde packt in den nachbardörfern mit
an
doch dies ist nur möglich wenn
gastronomen und hoteliers überleben
wir helfen wo wir können auch in den
krisengebieten
aber es geht ja um existenzen und
deshalb ist es auch wichtig und wir
hoffen dass die menschen uns
unterstützen und hier weiter urlaub
machen es ist ein zwiespalt für die
ganze region die vom tourismus lebt
günter becker vermietet boote am rursee
mit einer spendenaktion möchte er den
hochwassergeschädigten gebieten helfen
doch dafür sind sie dringend auf
touristen angewiesen wir geben
vom umsatz 10 prozent ab die wir direkt
den flutopfern spenden
das kommt dann der gemeinde schneiden
oder dem kreisgericht zugute tourismus
bleibt ein sensibles thema für die
eifelaner sie wollen nicht vergessen
sondern in der katastrophe mit ihren
mitteln bestmöglich helfen
viele menschen haben bereits gespendet
so sind schon fast 64 millionen euro
durch die zdf spendenaktion
zusammengekommen
wenn auch sie helfen wollen das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe hat ein
spendenkonto eingerichtet
die iban lautet de 65 104 106 100 104
106 100 stichwort zdf hochwasser und
weitere informationen finden sie unter
spenden punkt zdf.de und dem zdf text
auf seite 8 190 und wir schauen in die
türkei dort sorgt ein brutales
verbrechen für aufregung
es geht um den mord an einer kurdischen
familie in der zentral türkischen
provinz konya während
menschenrechtlerinnen von einem
rassistischen mord ausgehen spricht die
türkische regierung von einer alten
familienfehde air base berichtet es war
offenbar ein nachbarschaftsstreit der
aber schlägt wellen im ganzen land seit
jahren sei die kurdische familie von den
nachbarn bedroht worden
wir wollen hier keine kurden habe es
geheißen im mai erst wurde die familie
brutal überfallen gestern dann kam es zu
einem massaker bei dem sieben menschen
starben
es war nur ein angreifer vor dem stall
saßen zwei mädchen die hatte erschossen
die mutter und noch ein mädchen hat er
im haus erschossen unter den kurden in
der türkei brach ein sturm der empörung
los für viele sind die morde ausdruck
zunehmender kurden feindlichkeit im land
geschürt durch eine aggressive politik
der regierung so kommentierten
abgeordnete der prokurdischen hdp die
morde von konya tatsächlich betreibt die
regierung von präsident erdogan ein
parteiverbotsverfahren gegen die hdp
immerhin drittstärkste kraft im
parlament
der vorwurf die partei sei der
verlängerte arm der kurdischen
terrororganisation pkk die stimmung im
land ist gereizt sogar hinter den
waldbränden der vergangenen tage
vermuten viele die pkk der innenminister
versucht die lage zu beruhigen
das hat nichts mit türken und kurden zu
tun
zu versuchen daraus einen konflikt zu
machen ist gefährlich genau wie das
massaker abscheulich ist wäre auch
dieser versuch abscheulich die morde von
konya schüren hass und wut nicht auf den
täter sondern auf den politischen gegner
ein weiteres beispiel das zeigt wie
gespalten das land zurzeit ist
in süd und südosteuropa ist es gerade
extrem heiß und extrem trocken in
griechenland herrschen heute 40 grad und
die temperaturen sollen sogar noch
stärker steigen
besonders angespannt ist die lage auch
in italien auf der beliebten
urlaubsinsel sizilien brennt es etwa 150
menschen aus der gegend um catania
mussten in sicherheit gebracht werden
annette hilsenbeck berichtet sie sind in
panik versuchen das feuer zu löschen
dass ihr haus nahe der sizilianischen
stadt catania zu verschlingen droht in
mehreren vierteln der stadt brennt es
zehn feuerwehreinheiten kommen zum
einsatz
ein strandbad meerfeld den flammen zum
opfer
150 menschen wurden von der küstenwache
gerettet
viele menschen sind in panik in richtung
mehr geflohen
es war eine apokalypse flüge vom
flughafen catania wurden gestern
ausgesetzt um löschflugzeuge und
helikopter nicht zu behindern
inzwischen sind die brände hier unter
kontrolle doch in anderen teilen
siziliens brennt es heute weiter medien
berichten von 250 einsätzen der
feuerwehr in den letzten 24 stunden in
der region palermo fachen intensive
winde die vielen brände zusätzlich an
der bürgermeister eines betroffenen
ortes spricht von brandstiftung war noch
bio operation
das ist nicht das werk eines verrückten
oder eines pyromanen
wir haben kriminelle organisationen mit
gegen zerstört die hitzewelle die die
brände begünstigt soll noch bis 6 august
anhalten auf sizilien bleibt man in
alarmbereitschaft
seit diesem wochenende sind denn ganz
deutschland schulferien und während die
einen mit dem auto in den urlaub
losfahren kommen die anderen schon
wieder zurück entsprechend eng wurde es
vor allem auf den bayerischen autobahnen
hier etwa auf der a8 südlich von münchen
vor allem die rückreisenden mussten
stundenlange verzögerungen in kauf
nehmen aber auch richtung nord- oder
ostsee staute sich der verkehr
wir kommen zu olympia und zu norbert es
gab nur eine einzige deutsche medaille
magere ausbeute heute am achten
wettkampftag einmal bronze und zwar ganz
überraschend im judo mixed das ist
erstmals im olympischen programm
in einem verbissen geführten duell
setzten sich die deutschen judoka gegen
die niederlande durch
erschöpft aber glücklich das deutsche
mixed judo team bei der siegerehrung
hatten auch den spirit brauchten um
einfach beim stark zu sein und haben
zusammengehalten uns allen gezeigt was
wir drauf haben und das zeigten die
deutschen auch immer wieder wurden die
angriffe der starken niederländischen
mannschaft abgewehrt und punkte gemacht
am ende hieß es dann auch 4 zu 2 für
deutschland
damit bot die deutsche judo mannschaft
insgesamt drei bronzemedaillen in tokio
und zwei deutsche stabhochspringer haben
das olympia finale erreicht wo kann die
tabelle hat sich qualifiziert und weckt
damit zarte medaillenhoffnung genauso
wie oleg zernicke neun jahre ist es ja
dass es zählbares für deutsche in dieser
disziplin gegeben hat zwei dopingfälle
in der leichtathletik betroffen sind der
kenianische läufer marco jambo und die
nigerianische top-sprinterin blessing
abare sie galt als eine mit favoritin
für die 100 meter beide wurden vor den
wettkämpfen suspendiert und dem 109 100
meter finale der frauen gab es heute
einen jamaikanischen dreifach erfolg und
einen olympischen rekord dazu jamaica
gegen jamaika gegen jamaika die
sprintnation in gelb grün auf den bahnen
4 5 und 7
am start shelly ann fraser pryce auf
bahn fünf schießt aus dem block wird zum
dritten mal olympisches gold dann kommt
die titelverteidigerinnen thorsten herra
die beiden gleichauf bissig formen
herabsetzen kann jubelt schon und läuft
mit 10,61 neuen olympischen rekord
shelly ann fraser pryce mit 10 74 nur
selber schwer enttäuscht genauso cherry
jackson auf platz drei und die alte und
neue olympiasiegerin
thompson herra so schnell wie noch nie
eine frau in einem olympischen finale
100 meter lauf fürs geschichtsbuch der
leichtathletik und weitere
sportnachrichten aus tokio jetzt kurz
zusammengefasst und wir beginnen mit dem
erfolgsversprechenden deutschen
vielseitigkeits team
sie sind auf dem besten weg zu gold
vielseitigkeitsreiter michael jung hat
sich an seinem 39 geburtstag zum
top-favoriten auf einzel-gold
aufgeschwungen
mit fehlerfreiem ritt hat er auch die
deutsche equipe wieder auf medaillenkurs
gebracht morgen folgt der lauf durchs
gelände
die entscheidung dann am montag im
springen daumen hoch für die deutschen
beach-volleyballer julius tode und
clemens winkler sie ziehen als
gruppenzweite in die ko runde ein
gegen die japanische java und schira
tore gewannen die vize-weltmeister
locker in zwei sätzen
im achtelfinale am montag treffen sie
auf die us amerikaner gibb und worden
sie strebt eine vordere platzierung an
bmx freestylerin lara lissmann nach
überstandenem schlüsselbeinbruch vor
zwei monaten zeigt sie heute in den
setzlisten läufen eine gute leistung
wird am ende sechster bmx freestyle ist
in tokio erstmals olympisch das finale
mit lara listmann morgen früh gucke ich
mir an das war's von sport danke den
norbert und wir schauen noch kurz aufs
wetter ergiebiger regen kommt im süden
deutschlands auf die details dazu hat
für sie gleich osten telli das heute
journal sehen sie heute um 22.45 mit
claus kleber
wir wünschen ihnen noch einen schönen
samstagabend
[Musik]
schon kommt in den nächsten stunden und
vor allem in der zweiten nachthälfte
kommt ergiebiger regen im süden
deutschlands auf das kommt aus den alpen
heraus und wird teilweise unwetterartig
sein es kann große regenmengen zusammen
kommen und erst am nachmittag lässt es
von westen her nach außerdem bekommen
wir weiterhin kühle luft aus dem
nordwesten und so steigen die
temperaturen gerade mal auf 23 grad
morgen die regenmengen sind groß vor
allem richtung allgäu 50 liter und
darüber vor allem in der nähe von
gewittern kann es dann zu großen
regenmengen kommen ansonsten im norden
auch etwas regen das wird aber nicht
ganz so viel sein
in der kommenden nacht im norden also
etwas regen teils mit blitz und donner
im süden aber andauernder regen und
dazwischen bleibt es trocken mit
tiefsten temperaturen von 9 bis 14 im
süden und 15 grad an der nordsee und
morgen im tagesverlauf weitere schauer
und gewitter und ergiebiger regen noch
und dann lässt es allmählich nach im
nordwesten auch teils mit schauern blitz
und donner ist auch dabei freundlich
gerade mal nach norden bei temperaturen
bis 23 grad in den nördlichen
landesteilen und 15 grad ganz im süden
ja und die kommenden tage am montag
weitere schauer und gewitter 18 bis 22
grad und auch in den folgenden tagen
müssen wir mit schauern rechnen ein
schöner abend